good morning Hank it's Friday you know
I'm a professional video blogger because
I used my dog for white balancing so
Hank remember in 2008 when you in the
Katherine and I piled into a minivan and
played cows and traveled the country on
the tour de nerdfighting by the way if
you like my new shoes also are you
allowed to wear Pumas with black socks I
think so I think that's the rule right
so anyway Hank three-and-a-half years
later you and the Katherine and I are
going back on tour to celebrate the
release of The Fault in Our Stars except
this time with a slightly larger vehicle
in the hopes that at the end of it we
will still like each other what is it
Esther day so Hank today I'm gonna
answer nerdfighters questions about the
tour beginning with where are you going
alright all in one take Boston New York
City Washington DC Raleigh North
Carolina
Atlanta Georgia Birmingham Alabama New
Orleans Louisiana Houston Texas Austin
Texas Albuquerque New Mexico Tempe
Arizona Santa Monica California San
Francisco California Portland Oregon
Seattle Washington and Vancouver Canada
stop saying we never come to you can the
work away or if you weren't able to
follow along here's a nice map designed
by the inimitable Karen Cabot as you'll
notice like early human civilizations we
are mostly sticking to the coast this is
not because we do not love the great
corn-fed center of the United States
it's because it's snowing there in
January and we are going to be in a car
ish thing so Midwest this is me hugging
you saying I'm sorry
we'll be there next time I love I like
you when does this tour start January
10th the day the book comes out and it
ends January 31st so is this to are
going to be free or what hmm
or what bookstores have basically always
lost money by hosting Tour de
nerdfighting events and that has to
change because in the last three years
hundreds of bookstores have closed
costing tens of thousands of American
jobs many of them nerdfighter jobs so in
most cases the price of admission is the
price of a copy of The Fault in Our
Stars bought from the bookstore in
question we're working with some of the
best independent bookstores in the world
from politics and prose in Washington DC
to Powell's in Portland and we want to
support them but you get a free book
that's signed and Hank ler fished and
you also get a poster and you get an
amazing show that's gonna feature
singing and reading and discussion and a
little bit of electrocution also
puppetry that may not be a selling point
what would these events be like I just
told you there's gonna be electrocution
what else do you want no it's gonna be
amazing
I'm gonna read from The Fault in Our
Stars Hank's gonna play songs we're all
gonna do fun stuff together there's
gonna be amazing discussions it's gonna
be really fun are you gonna sign books
and everything yes and Hank will also be
signing CDs you have to have that many
buttons unbuttoned on your shirt it's
kind of awkward oh sorry I didn't notice
my bad here I'll just go all the way up
so that you don't have to worry at all
okay
yeah that's that's gonna be better for
everybody actually it's kind of hard to
take you seriously now like just just
there is that that's good how do I get
tickets tickets are going pretty fast
like the event in New York is actually
already almost sold out sorry about that
we're trying to have a second event in
New York but there's lots of information
in the doobly-doo where you can find out
where to call or click or whatever to
get tickets
so to summarize Hank Catherine me and
occasionally the Yeti will be on tour in
January of 2012 there is more
information in the doobly-doo in the
meantime hey the project for awesome is
coming up have you started working on
your project for awesome video yet I've
started working on mine not to say that
I mad of you but I think I might be
ahead of you so you should probably
start doing it for those who don't know
the project for awesome is an annual
event in which youtubers upload videos
about their favorite charities on
December 17th so start making your video
now so you can upload it then and yes
I'm unbuttoning buttons because I read
on the internet that that makes you
listen to me when I talk about charity
oh that that only works for really
pretty people why are you always so mean
to me off screen figment of my
imagination Hank I'll see you on Monday